vous savez j'ai fait plus que soit son
film
ce dividende est choisi mais ils les
films que j'aime pour les raisons
différents par jour pour j'aime beaucoup
ce parc est ce parce que c'est toi
une histoire que j'adorais et j'adorais
de travail avec mes acteurs comme bon ce
levier pilou snof et il est les petits
films des films comme chemin de la
gloire
j'aime beaucoup parce que c'est un sujet
que je trouve très intéressant et aussi
c'est le commencement d'un gong talents
comme c'est un double j'adore j'aime
beaucoup les les westerns de temps en
temps que j'ai fais comment ok corral et
souvent il est un vieux comme life la
ville de van gogh
c'est difficile de trouver un seul film
il y a plusieurs firmes fij m pour
beaucoup de raisons à mon avis je suis
je suis d'accord souvent on fait les
choses ont fait le film seulement pour
gagner de l'argent mais c'est important
tout le monde nous sommes tous obligés
de gagner la vie mais je crois que c'est
possible au cinéma de fait un film at
his tic aussi de faire un film qui peut
gagner un peu d'argent par exemple le
film bat monfils
il a fait un one flo le coucou cesse à
mon avis c'est un pion qui a gagné
beaucoup d'argent mais à la fois je
crois que cet homme firmin vraiment
artistes et parmi les réalisateurs
français avec qui aimeriez-vous tourné
au il y en a beaucoup
où en est qu il y a pas louche trouve fu
crew t il ya beaucoup qui à mon avis ils
ont beaucoup de talent mais j'aime la
façon qu'ils travaillent ici parce que
c'est ça me donne l'impression que c'est
beaucoup plus simple c'est sait on prend
une idée on travaille ensemble et on ne
sent pas obligé de faire quelque chose
très grand pour gagner des millions pour
paix pour le fuel et il ça me plaira
beaucoup de fer ont fait au mauvais
comptes en banque un bon mettre en scène
est de rester ici en france pour 10
semaines